quand les grandes lignes ont été validés
j'ai choisi la méthode des groupes de
travail groupe de travail interservices
tous services de l'élysée d'ailleurs
parce que la sécurité à l'elysée ne
repose pas stricto sensu sûr j'espère
est le commanditaire
il ya d'autres services qui par leur
action puisse ou moins en marge de la
nôtre concours néanmoins à la fonction
sécurité donc nous avions opté pour des
groupes de travail et chaque groupe de
travail a été chargé d'une thématique
particulière par exemple il y avait un
groupe de travail mutualisation gronder
travail convergence des moyens et etc
etc
voilà et aujourd'hui parce que ces
travaux ont commencé en janvier 2018
aujourd'hui ils sont quand même bien
bien avancé et il passe il passe par
encore quelques quelques réflexions et
quelques et quelques travaux pratiques
si je puis dire avant avant d'aboutir
comme je vous l'aï dit cesser ces
travaux étaient interservices donc tous
les services étaient étaient représentés
nous souhaitions être certain de ne rien
oublier dans la réflexion alexandre
benalla participer à certains de ces
travaux
en tant que représentant des chefferies
le cabinet positionnement intéressant
pour
pour moi puisque ils sont bien là était
dans ses fonctions un petit peu à la
charnière entre ce que fait de jeu
espère et commandant militaire
il était souvent justement dans cette
zone interface entre l'intérieur et
l'extérieur
par ailleurs alexandre benalla avait
suivi de près emmanuel macron ce qu'il
était candidat il s'est occupé de
sécurité et donc ils avaient la proche
humaine de ce que souhaitait le
président pour sa sécurité
il avait bien cette cet aspect très
particulier que qui relève de la
personnalité de chaque président qui
pour autant ne peut pas être exclue
d'une réflexion à cette échelle il faut
savoir ce que souhaite le président en
france en tout cas on ne peut pas
imposer totalement un carcan de sécurité
au président de république
donc il faut connaître également sa sa
sensibilité puisque ses attendus
je parle de sensibilité sa manière de
concevoir sa protection rapprochée
donc il faut intégrer dans la réflexion
réelle centre benalla était est et était
là également pour ça